[Applause]
they wanted to shoot it Hey
money in the bank I've been working on
militina a below-average three-point
shooter there
ladies and gentlemen here's history take
a look
another isolation with a with a smaller
defender now or been against Jaron grant
there's that mid-range and it looked
pretty smooth the donkeys already led by
as many as 13 difficult Sean Ben Simmons
that went up it's like what is he doing
serve as a blueprint mark for how a guy
like JoEllen Beach get itself
incorporated into game good lessons
learned here tonight
that senate's adding to that rookie
career-high give him 27 tonight taking
the ball off the dribble Simmons could
fake and gets it to go Ben Simmons
decimal I really didn't have any doubt
that he would get it straight down Ben
Simmons starts with a jump shot and fans
him don't try to play him out here for
let him make his jumper he's gonna try
to put it down and get by make him take
a jump shot
Simmons make him make a jump shot look
at this jump hook over a good defender
and look vincent's right up there with
him and on Simmons with a hot potato has
to get rid of it Simmons and they face
shot clock violation I thought he got I
thought the whistle was blown
I thought zeros in the shock pop six of
nine survives as we point wise
[Music]
you know much it looked like he shot
that turnaround jumper flatfoot II gotta
hurry now that ball went all the way to
the opposite baseline shot clock at
three Simmons
Ben Simmons bring it in the air yeah
this is the lineup Poston beat after the
injury that had such a great run at the
end of the regular season a Simmons Wow
was the shot well double for the rookie
look at that shot heard that Johnny
[Applause]
Simmons guarded by Horford falling away
it's good citizen double figures nice
job by Dorian finney-smith but it's
unable to do much against Ben Simmons
Simmons against Bradley gave the
shoulder and properly drills the jump
shot of him watch Ben here how he goes
right at Bret for the Grizzlies they
averaged 27 attempts per game
Simmons top shot eventually
marShon Brooks see where he's so far
he's that far back away so that means
that Ben Simmons has the running start
three Frosty's I don't know who'd care
they can get can you get him on
Thanksgiving yes give me 20 degrees
tomorrow
[Applause]
Butler got the little Speights and hit
the side of the blackboard Simmons with
a rare jumper
Ben Simmons with a mid-range jumper well
thanks you gotta watch it here now as it
comes out he picks it up and then just
looks at the basket realizes he read the
clock before you talk nice meet bill
gold this half Mitchell is 3 for 8 from
behind the arc tears and water by Penn
Simmons a mid-range you know less about
the mid-range for Simmons in one of
those fixers and this is all that he
needs to do couple dribbles and a little
fade away
[Applause]
and taking John Collins going Winnebago
a juicer and he hurried it cause it
could have playing risk contact whether
it's defensively or offensively
something teen out of 18 right here on
their home floor
[Applause]
Simmons against Gibson and he got it
done Ben Simmons try to do your thing
and atone for you know the best part
about the NBA is the schedule allows you
for a lot of opportunities to redeem
yourself there's a game coming up to
take a look at to 5:00 on Barnes Barnes
not giving him the lane the fadeaway
over the right shoulder
watch this again the elbow in given that
a chant so lose against Brogdon backs
his way in and then send his first field
goal of the quarter Ben Simmons who has
been marvelous and that's an
understatement
Simmons again
76ers also have a say in controlled the
amount of energy they provide in
particular on the road
Simmons extra track play of one been set
up we knew coming in that this probably
beat the game that was over early so
there'd be some free opportunities no
pressure situations wide open